hundreds of dollars of fake money an
injured son that's what a small business
owner says she's left with after
customers came to pick up their order
this all unfolded back in the east
valley in late august victoria saha
speaking to the woman today directly she
has the exclusive story
jessica saucedo loves making
personalized items for customers right
from her home and when she got a large
order to make glamorous invitations she
went all in only for it to be a huge
wake-up call mom of three jessica socedo
pours her heart and soul into her
crafting business so when she got an
order for 150 invitations she got to
work i would come home and i would stay
up until two or three o'clock in the
morning trying to finish these
invitations sauceros says the customer
sent her 400 dollars with the remaining
balance of another 400 to be paid during
pickup but so cedo says when it was time
for the customer to pick up and finish
paying the customer was sending someone
else and so cedo had to send her son to
collect the money as she was working
they took out the money but they gave it
to him folded my son was like you know
he grabbed it socedo says the person
handed her son fake hundred dollar bills
then in a haste to leave ran over his
foot that could have turned out so much
worse when soceto checked with the
customer she was allegedly told the
customer had no idea who that person
picking up the order was but when she
asked for the remaining balance the
customer left her hanging people like
that make you lose that trust on good
people leaving the family out of money
they desperately needed with this money
this is what this bill is going to be
covered and this is what this is going
to be
and
that that week my husband had to like
try to find another side job try to do
so much so ceto says she reached out to
me to share her story because she
doesn't want any other small business
owners to trust so blindly again from
now on she says she will only be
sticking to electronic payments victoria
saha 8 news now